GOOD MORNING WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TO THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND COMMUTERS ELEMENT
MEETING OF WEDNESDAY APRIL THIRD
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS FOR A QUORUM SO I'M
GONNA ASK ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE JOIN US BUT
IN THE ABSENCE.
OF A QUORUM WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
FIRST ITEM WE ARE GOING TO CALL
IS MR BLOOM'S ITEM.
WHICH IS AB.
FOR A SORRY IT'S LINE ITEM FOR
A. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT EIGHT ONE MISTER BUSH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'LL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
ONGOING WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS NEED NO
INTRODUCTION HERE THERE -- OLD
INNOVATION THAT -- WE'VE --
BREATHE NEW LIFE AND INTO HERE
IN CALIFORNIA -- UNFORTUNATELY
THEY'RE STILL BARRIERS TO
CONSTRUCTION IN AB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE SIX TO REDUCE SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS BY UPDATING AND
CLARIFYING THE PROVISIONS OF THE
EIGHTIES STATURE.
TO CLARIFY SOME DEFINITIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS REMOVES PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE GIVEN CITIES --
BROADER -- DISCRETION AND THAN
THEY SHOULD HAVE FOR DENYING A
DO YOU PERMITS AND IT REMOVES
SAID THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE. EIGHTY IS CAN HELP US
AND ACTUALLY ARE HELPING US --
CLOSE TO THE HOUSING GAP BAND --
THESE UNITS ARE AN EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD THE BY THE VERY NATURE
OFTEN AFFORDABLE.
ESPECIALLY FOR POPULATIONS SUCH
AS STUDENTS YOUNG PROFESSIONALS
AND SENIORS.
AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE WILL HELP
pEIGHTY IS REALIZE EVEN GREATER
POTENTIAL THAN THEY'VE ALREADY
CHIEFS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR OF A THANK YOU AWARENESS.
LOUIS MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIA BE
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT EIGHTY USE
ARE CRITICAL PART OF MAKING
CALIFORNIA PLACE WHERE EVERYONE
CAN DRIVE THEIR SMART.
NON CONTROVERSIAL CAN HAD
THOUSANDS OF NEW HOMES -- IT TO
THE STATE IN A IN A GENTLE WAY.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON AB.
EIGHT EIGHT ONE THANK YOU LET ME
ASK OF THE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT --
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
INJURED BECAUSE OUR REPRESENTING
CVA THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CBA HAS A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION WE
AGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOONS INTENT TO PREVENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM REQUIRING.
ON OUR OCCUPANCY TO ISSUE AN
EIGHTY YOU A PERMIT FOR AN
EIGHTY YEAR HOWEVER WE THINK THE
LANGUAGE.
IT LEAVES ENOUGH AMBIGUITY THAT
THE LOCALS CAN IT STILL WILL
PASS ORDINANCES REQUIRING HONOR
OCCUPANCY.
SO WELL WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE OFFICE ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THE MAJOR IMPEDIMENTS TO EIGHTY
YOU CONSTRUCTION.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
LANGUAGE WE TIGHTENED THE REASON
THAT THE WINGS BEHIND TO REMOVE
AMBIGUITY THANK YOU.
ME ASK IF THERE ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS SAY NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEN NONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY -- HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL -- IN A MISTER
BLOOM HAS BEEN A TIRELESS
ADVOCATE FOR EIGHTY USE -- THIS
PARTICULAR SURE OF IT OF ON OUR
OCCUPANCY.
HAS BEEN ONE THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING OVER THE YEARS -- BUT
I THINK WE'VE CERTAINLY SEEN IN
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES MY OWN --
THAT WE CAN HAVE SUCCESSFUL
EIGHTY YOU POLICIES EVEN WITHOUT
AN OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENT --
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS HAS BEEN
AN IMPEDIMENT TO THE CREATION OF
A TO USE SO WITH THAT.
I THINK -- MANY OF US WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE FORWARD IN A DIRECTION
OF SEE HOW THIS WORKS AND WITH
THAT -- I DO PLAN TO SUPPORT BUT
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS.
FOR A VOTE AT THIS TIME SO WANT
WE PASS OVER UNTIL WE DO AND
WE'LL LET YOU GET TO YOUR
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANKS.
WHEN HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN --
LET'S GO NEXT TO FILE ITEM SEVEN
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
MISTER GRAYSON
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND LET YOU KNOW
THAT I AM.
MORE THAN WILLING TO ACCEPT AND
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS AUTHOR -- AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
ACCORDING TO A NATIONAL SURVEY
CALIFORNIA'S DEVELOPMENT FEES
ARE NEARLY THREE TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE RESEARCH
SUGGEST THAT THESE DEVELOPMENT
FEES ARE OFTEN PASSED ALONG TO
HOME BUYERS PUTTING
HOMEOWNERSHIP FURTHER OUT OF
REACH FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS.
A TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT
BY UC BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER
FOUND THAT DEVELOPMENT FEES CAN
BE DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE.
ARE HIGHLY VARIABLE ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT PROJECTS
ARE OFTEN SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL
EXACTIONS NOT CODIFIED IN ANY
FEE SCHEDULE ALL OF THESE
FACTORS COMBINED TO MAKE
DEVELOPMENT RISKIER MORE COSTLY
AND ALTERNATELY SERVE TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING.
THAT GETS BUILT IN OUR STATE.
GIVEN THE EXTENT OF OUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS WE NEED TO EXPLORE ALL
THE OPTIONS TO REDUCE BARRIERS
TO DEVELOPMENT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE A DEVELOPMENT PROPONENT
WITH A GOOD FAITH STATEMENT
DISCLOSE THE DISCLOSING THE
AMOUNT OF IMPACT AND DEVELOPMENT
FEES.
APPLICABLES TO A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND WILL PROHIBIT
LOCAL AGENCIES FROM INCREASING
THESE FEES FOR TWO YEARS AFTER
THE TIME THE DEVELOP AN
APPLICATION IS DEEMED COMPLETE.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE
LOCAL AGENCY TO PRO -- TO POSE
ON ITS WEBSITE A LIST OF ALL
FEES APPLICABLES TO A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
THESE CHANGES TO EXISTING LAW
WILL ADD MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY AND CERTAINTY TO
THE HOUSING DEVELOP A PROCESS
REDUCINGCOST AND LENGTH OF
DEVELOPMENT CYCLE AND ALSO ONLY
HELPING TO ADDRESS.
OUR ON GOING HOUSING CRISIS WITH
ME TODAY OR TWO WITNESSES MERRY
ON A WIRE -- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM AND ALSO
ANDREW BECAUSE OF OUR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MY NAME IS
INJURED BECAUSE IT ARE IN ON THE
SCIENTIST AND LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE AT THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
CBA.
CBI IS A STATE WIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING.
THIRTY ONE HUNDRED IT'S INVOLVED
IN RESIDENTIAL AND LIGHT
COMMERCIAL CONSTRUCTION CVA
MEMBER COMPANIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR CONSTRUCTING OVER 85% OF THE
NEW HOMES BUILT IN CALIFORNIA
EACH YEAR.
C. A.'S PLEASE TO CO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY THE
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON A BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT LOCAL AGENCIES FROM
IMPOSING.
ANY ADDITIONAL FEES ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AFTER THE PROJECT
APPLICATION IS COMPLETE.
MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO NOT
PUBLISH THE SCHEDULES OR PROVIDE
ESTIMATES OF THOSE FEES AND THE
EFFECT OF THOSE FEES ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS HARD TO OVERSTATE.
IN A RECENT STUDY FOCUSED ON A
HANDFUL CALIFORNIA CITIES UC
BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION FOUND THE
DEVELOPMENT FEES OFTEN LIKE
TRANSPARENCY.
IMPOSE HIGH COST AND HAVE
ARBITRARY STRUCTURE OF THE CITY
OF THE SEVEN CITIES ANALYZE THEY
FOUND THAT FEES WERE UPWARDS OF
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT.
AT THE FEES CAN AMOUNT UPWARDS
OF 18% OF THE COST OF A MEDIAN
HOME.
DOES THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
COUPLED WITH A POTENTIALLY SIX
FIGURE FEES MAKE IT VERY HARD
FOR HOME BUILDERS TO ESTIMATE
COSTS IN ALREADY UNCERTAIN
TUMULTUOUS MARKET.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THAT
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
AGREEING LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
TO THE PROCESS -- AS AS
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES WITH
HOUSING CRAP HOUSING CRISIS SUCH
TRANSPARENCY IS SORELY NEEDED IN
ORDER TO REMOVE UNCERTAINTY AND
HELP ENCOURAGE HOMEBUILDING FOR
THESE REASONS.
CVA SUPPORTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR RESPECT AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE I'VE OF THANK YOU MISS
WHITE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM TEACH THESE
MEMBERS PRODUCED AND PRESERVE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
AS I KNOW YOU ARE WELL AWARE ONE
IN THREE CALIFORNIANS PAY MORE
THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOMES ON
RENT.
AND LOWER CAL INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY THIS CRISIS THE
STATE IS SHORT. ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION HOMES AFFORDABLE TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO ADD MORE
CERTAINTY TO THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS WILL ALLOW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO BUILD MORE
UNITS.
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND THAT AND
MAKE A BIGGER DENT IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS THIS
IS YCC IS PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
FORTY FOUR AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
LET'S MOVE TO OTHER SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBER
YELLING AVERAGE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WERE ALSO.
A PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED WE PLEASE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NEXT PAR GOOD MORNING SO AS A
MATTER NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY HABITAT
CALIFORNIA AFFILIATE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ENDLESS MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIA
BID SUPPORT.
SENATE GEORGE WITH THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WERE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE
WORKED ON A SIMILAR BILL -- LAST
YEAR WITH THAT IN THAT SENATOR
CAFIERO -- WE DO NEED SOME
TECHNICAL CHANGES BEYOND WHAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
RECOMMENDED AND COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE IN ORDER TO CALCULATE
THE FEES WITHOUT THAT WE CAN'T
DO IT -- WE DO NEED TO HAVE THE
FEES THEMSELVES TIED DOWN TO
SPECIFIC DEFINITIONS SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHICH FEES ARE GOING. TO
BE INCLUDED IN THE BILL -- WE
ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE THE FEES THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE THOSE
IMPOSED ON THE HOUSING UNITS IN
A DEVELOPMENT PROJECT NOT JUST
THE ENTIRE.
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT AND MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE FEES CALCULATED
WOULD BE FOR THE UNITS THE
HOUSING UNITS IN A PROJECT IF
IT'S MIXED USE IT WOULD NOT BE
COMMERCIAL SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THINGS YOU STILL LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
BY THE SUPPORTERS [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
IS ONE OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD THIS IS A
CONCEPT -- I HAVE SUPPORTED
BEFORE -- AND I THINK I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYONE WHO THINKS
THAT THE FEES WE HAVE AROUND THE
STATE ARE.
CRITICALLY RATIONAL -- OR AT
LEAST ALL THE FEES THAT WE HAVE --
I ALSO WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE WAS
A BILL.
THAT REQUIRES EACH C. D. TO
STUDY FEES AND THAT WAS AUTHORED
BY THIS BY OUR AUTHOR TODAY.
A VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE RESULTS OF THAT -- AND AS
THE AUTHOR NOT DISCUSSED -- AM
HOPEFUL THAT TO DEPENDING ON
WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT WE MAY
SEE FUTURE MOMENTS TO THIS BILL
THAT MAY TACKLE THAT -- WOULD
ASK THE AUTHOR IF WE COULD -- IT
AS AS AMENDMENTS MOVE FOR BE IN
DISCUSSION WITH YOU ON THAT AND
I KNOW THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO -- BUT I THINK
THIS IS -- DEFINITELY TOPIC THAT
WE SHOULD TACKLE THIS YEAR AND
VERY MUCH COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
YOUR SPONSORS FOR A MOVING THIS
FORWARD -- WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT AS SOON AS WE DO WE
WILL TAKE A MOTION OF IT FOR ME
ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I FELT
GREAT THANK YOU.
SURE WE STILL HAVE A QUORUM AT
THIS TIME BUT IN CASE FOLKS ARE
WANTING ABOUT THE MAKE UP OF
TODAY'S COMMITTEE WITH A COUPLE
OF ILLNESSES SO -- WE HAVE
MISTER STONE WHO'S GOING TO BE
REPLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK SILVA AND WE HAVE
EVENTUALLY MISTER BONTA WHO'S
GONNA COME AND REPLACE BRIAN
MAIENSCHEIN JUST FOR TODAY
[inaudible]
SO WITHOUT.
IT WAS THE ONLY ONE MORE.
LET'S GO TO FILE ITEMS ONE AND
TWO ASK MISTER TING WHETHER YOU
LIKE TO START WITH FILE ITEM ONE
WHICH IS AB SIXTY EIGHT WELL
JUST TO AB SIXTY FIRST THAT'S
WRONG ORDER.
THIS YEAR -- FIRST IMAGES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND ARE YOUR
CONSULTANT FOR THE A. B.
AMENDMENTS WERE HAPPY TO TAKE
THEM -- OU TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
THE REALLY NEED FOR EIGHTY USES --
FAST AND AFFORDABLE WAY TO
REALLY ATTACK THIS.
HOUSING CRISIS THAT'S REALLY --
HITTING US ALL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE -- DID THIS BILL
STREAMLINES MANY THE PROVISIONS
SO THAT BUT STOP CITIES FROM
BASICALLY BANNING EIGHTY USE FOR
EXAMPLE.
MON HAS A LOCAL EIGHTY YOU
ORDINANCE NOT ALLOWING EIGHTY
USE ON ANY LOTS THAT ARE LESS
THAN EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE FEET --
SO UNFORTUNATELY IT'S ALMOST
LIKE A DE FACTO BAN IN THAT TYPE
OF CITY WE SEE THAT IN CITIES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE -- THIS BILL
STREAMLINES IT REALLY ENCOURAGES
CITIES TO START BUILDING EIGHTY
USE REALLY ALLOWING IT USED TO
BE BUILT -- WE REALLY SEE THIS
AS A FAST AFFORDABLE WAY TO GET
HOUSING PRODUCTION -- BUILD UP
IN THE IN THE STATE WE HAVE TO
TWO GREAT WITNESSES WE HAVE
LOOSE -- MERON TAPE FROM MY
CALIFORNIAN B. AND HELEN LEON
FROM HELLO HOUSING.
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING -- LIST MONDAY WITH
CALIFORNIA BE -- I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT RESEARCH FROM UC
BERKELEY SHOWS EIGHTY IS COST
LESS TO BUILD AND TO RENT --
THEN COMMENCE HERBAL APARTMENT
UNITS I'M MAKING A MOVE IN
AFFORDABLE AND ECO FRIENDLY
SOURCE OF NEW HOUSING ARE JUST
PART.
HELEN LEARN A WITH LA MUST WEAR
NONPROFIT URBAN DESIGN
ORGANIZATION BASED IN LOS
ANGELES WE'VE ALSO BEEN
SUPPORTING THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES UNDER
EIGHTY YOU PILOT PROJECTS.
DEMONSTRATING HOW EIGHTY USE CAN
BE CONTRACTUALLY DESIGN A POORLY
BUILT AND HELP WITH THEIR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
I'M AND IN LA SINCE STATE LAW
PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
HAVE SEEN NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
PERMITS.
ON EIGHTY IS AND THAT'S A
REFLECTION OF NOT HAVING
RESTRICTIONS ON OWNER OCCUPANCY
LOT SIZES FOR ERROR RATIO AND
AND A LOT COVERAGE SO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION BECAUSE WE HAVE
LAUNCHED A PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES TO HELP AVERAGE
HOMEOWNERS BECOME PROVIDERS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'VE HAD
LOTS OF HOMEOWNERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING THIS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM.
AND MANY HOMEOWNERS ACTUALLY
WISH THEY COULD DO MORE THAN ONE
EIGHTY YOU AND DO IT ON A MULTI
PROPERTY LOT SO THAT'S AN
EXCITING COMPONENT THE BILL
WHICH WOULD ENCOURAGE.
MORE HOMERS PARTICIPATE IN LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE HALF A MILLION
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS AND MANY MORE
MULTI FAMILY UNIT LOTS.
I IF THIS BILL PASSES WE BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN.
HAVE EIGHTY USE AS A HOUSING
TYPOLOGY THAT CAN SUPPORT NOT
JUST MORE HOUSING UNITS BUT ALSO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPECTRUM UP CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
SAYS THE MATTER THAT LAYS OUT
LATE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I'M BREANNA SIMMONS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI AM DEBBIE SANDERSON WITH A DO
YOU TASK FORCE WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT.
AND LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION OR TWEETERS.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LEARNED ABLE ANTI REPRESENT
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND WE ACTUALLY DID PUT IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED LETTER IN
PRIOR TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE -- MADE BUT WE REALLY
APPECIATE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE I THINK WE'RE REALLY
CLOSE ACTUALLY TO BEING ABLE TO
GO NEUTRAL ON THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE THEM AND STILL ALLOW
FOR SOME FAA ARE AND A LOT
COVERAGE STANDARDS IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS.
I'M STILL WANT TO WORK ON THE
MULTI FAMILY AND EIGHTY USE AND
THAT MAYBE SOME PARAMETERS
AROUND THE AMOUNT THAT ARE IN A
MULTI FAMILY UNITS BUT OTHER
EITHER WAY -- WERE REALLY
APPRECIABLE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE THANK YOU.
AND BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR A NOSE
DEDICATION -- TO WAITING INTO
THIS TOPIC OF EIGHTY USE AND
THIS IS A BILL THAT -- WILL
CERTAINLY HELP TO REMOVE SOME
THE EXISTING IMPEDIMENTS TO
BUILDING AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN
UNITS -- THIS IS ALL DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT I SUPPORT -- WE
STILL DO NOT YET HAVE QUIRK
ACTUALLY I THINK WE JUST THAT
QUORUM.
SO ONE WE JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY.
CHIU HERE HERE DEEP.
DEEP HERE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GLORIA GLORIA HERE
KILEY.
WE MON.
LIMóN HERE BONTA [inaudible]
STONE.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE QUORUM LET
ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS DISRESPECT RESTAURANT
OKAY -- COULD HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
IT'S A MOTION TO MOVE SECONDED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT HI
TO HI.
I DAVE.
NOT.
NINE FORTY GET RID GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY [inaudible]
LEE MON [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
STONE.
YOUR BILL STILL NEEDS A FEW MORE
VOTES BUT WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS
WHO CAN ADD ONS WE WILL HOLD IT
UNTIL THEN -- WHEN WE MOVED TO
FILE ITEM -- TO AB SIXTY NINE
THANK YOU -- I'M TO EIGHTY SIX
NIGHTS ANOTHER EIGHTY YOU BILL --
QUITE SIMPLY AB SIXTY NINE
EXPEDITED CONSTRUCTION OF COST
EFFECTIVE EIGHTY USED BY
CREATING A SMALL HOUSE BUILDING
STANDARDS CODE THAT REFLECTS THE
UNIQUE NATURE OF THE UNITS THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING CAN DEVELOP
WILL BE TASKED.
WITH DRAFTING STANDARDS
EMPHASIZING COST EFFECTIVENESS.
INCLUDE GUIDANCE IS FOR SMALL
KITCHENS AND BATHROOMS AND SMALL
APPLIANCES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BY THE FOR
EIGHTY AB [inaudible]
SIXTY NINE YOUR WITNESSES.
AT LUIS WERE ON TAKEN WITH
CALIFORNIA BE I JUST ADD THAT AB
SIXTY NINE I IS GOING -- TO
PROVIDE COST EFFECTIVE
GUIDELINES AND INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO FALL THEM AS THEY
RELATE TO SMALL -- SMALL HOMES.
IT'S GONNA AT THOUSANDS OF NEW
UNITS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING STOCK
THAT ARE URGENTLY NEEDED I OR
DRIVE.
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS -- INJURED
BECAUSE IT ARE WOULD SEE I A
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CBA'S PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB SIXTY NINE AUTHORED
BY THE HONORABLE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING.
AB SIXTY NINE DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMITTEE
VELVETS PROPOSED BUILDING
STANDARDS FOR ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS OR HAITI IS.
ON THE ON HOMES AND HOMES THAT
ARE MORE THAN A HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET.
THE BILL ALSO STATES THAT THE
STANDARDS MUST BE COST EFFECTIVE
AS COST EFFECTIVE AS A STANDARDS
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA.
BUILDING STANDARDS CODES.
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE STANDARDS
AND MANDATES ALL OF WHICH WERE
ADDED TO THE BUILDING CODE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND AND SEVEN HAVE
ADDED APPROXIMATELY.
220-002-30000 DOLLARS TO THE
COST OF BUILDING EACH NEW HOME
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE ESTIMATES FOR EIGHTY USE I
IMAGINE THAT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE STANDARDS
AND CODES OR SIMILAR OR PERHAPS
A LITTLE LESS FOR AN EIGHTY YOU.
GIVEN THAT THERE'S STILL A
BASELINE INSTALLATION COST IN
THAT THERE'S ONLY A LITTLE BIT
SAVE THE MATERIAL AND LABOR
COSTS MOST OF THE STANDARDS
MANDATES ADDED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHILE COMMENDABLE
IN CONCEPT.
DO NOTHING FOR THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF THE OCCUPANTS
INSTEAD THESE STANDARDS -- I
CONSIDER COST COULD ULTIMATELY
BECOME AN INSURMOUNTABLE
OBSTACLE FOR HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE
SEEKING TO CONSTRUCT AND EIGHTY
YOU.
SO FOR THESE REASONS CDA
SUPPORTS AB SIXTY NINE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
LET ME ASK IF THE OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
I'M ARENA SIMMONS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KEEP DONE HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
SAYS THE NOT NOT WHAT HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS FOR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HI DEBBIE SANDERSON WITH A DO
YOU TASK FORCE STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION OR ANY TWEETERS.
SEEN ON LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
MR GLORIA -- AND FORGIVE ME --
MACHINE DID YOU TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT SO I DID I'M
SORRY I FORGOT.
ABOUT BACK AT THE THINK THE
CHAIR INTO THE COMMUNITY.
IT'S ALL GOOD AND WE WE
APPRECIATE COULD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE MR TING I'M HAPPY WITH THE
BILL WITHIN MINUTES THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL BE TAKEN
UP FOR TIME REASONS IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AGAIN THIS
IS ANOTHER BILL THAT WILL HELP
US TO MOVE FORTY DO YOU
PRODUCTION -- ACTUALLY I'M SORRY
THE MOVE THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MOVED TO APPROPRIATIONS NOT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND BE TAKEN
THERE -- BUT UNLESS OR ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS LET ME ASK IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS RESPECT
FOR HIS FATHER.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE IT FORD IS OUR SECOND.
OKAY -- CAN WE TAKE A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TWO FIVE TWO HI DEEP.
HI DAVE I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY
[inaudible]
LEE MON.
THE MONTH I BONTA [inaudible]
STONE.
YOUR BILL PASSES -- WE'LL WAIT
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S CALL IT MISTER MAYES.
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B..
TEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY ON A. B.. TEN EIGHTY
FOUR TODAY THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD ALLOW THE INDIAN WELLS
HOUSING AUTHORITY DEVELOP A
CAPITAL RESERVE USING THEIR
ACCESS SURPLUS FUNDS.
THESE FUNDS COME FROM THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME ASSET FUND.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE FUNDS TO
BE RESERVED FOR FOUR YEARS AND
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND
THAT TIME LINE TO EIGHT YEARS.
WITHOUT A LIKE TO HAND OVER
JASON'S OFFICE REPRESENTED CITY
MANUALS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING AND
SALAS REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
INDIAN WELLS -- AS THE AUTHORS
SAY THIS BILL ALLOWS THE VERY
FEW COMMUNITIES THAT BECAME
OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS POST
REDEVELOPMENT SOLUTION. TO
RETAIN THEIR CAPITAL RESERVES
FOR EIGHT YEARS RATHER THAN FOUR
YEARS THE CITY OF ANY WELLS
OPERATES TO COMMUNITIES ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN UNITS --
AND THIS ALLOWS THEM TO INSURE
THE LONG TERM VIABILITY OF THE
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN ORDER TO DO.
LARGER CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS HVAC
SYSTEMS PAINTING OF BUILDINGS
AND SO FORTH -- FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF WHAT THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS FOR THIS BILL
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AS OUR SECOND.
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR A
BRING THIS BILL TO US -- TO
REALLY GIVE MORE DISCRETION TO
HOUSING SUCCESSORS TO MAINTAIN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ASSETS --
THIS ADDS FLEXIBILITY BUT
DOESN'T ALLOW FUNDS THAT ARE
ACCUMULATING TO ACCUMULATE AND
DEFINITELY AND WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT -- LISTERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION TO HAVE ANY
FINAL CLOSING REMARKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR RESPECT HER BECAUSE
MY BOAT ALL RIGHT -- LET'S SICK
LOCAL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU HI.
HI DEEP DEEP I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY LEE MON
[inaudible]
I BONTA [inaudible]
STONE.
EVEN IF BILLS TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MAYES.
MYSTERY OF US.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS WITH US TODAY --
I'LL ASSUME MAYBE WANNA START
WITH FILE ITEM [inaudible]
SIX AB. TWELVE FIFTY FIVE WE
WOULD WANNA SO THAT WHICH EVER
YOU LIKE BUT THAT'S FOR STEP AND
VOTERS OF UNLESS YOU WANT TO
SPEND LESS YOU WANNA START WITH
THE OTHER ONE IS YOUR CALL
THAT'S WHEN WE START WITH THE OF
THE FIVE TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE FILE
AND SIX SURPLUS.
PUBLIC LANDS SO I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER STAFF WE WORK ON THIS
BILL -- AND IN -- TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU FOR
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THEM -- AND SO THIS
BILL AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE BUILDS
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. TO CREATE -- A DIGITIZE
INVENTORY OF SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTY.
THAT COULD BE USED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SO THIS
BILL CREATES A SEARCHABLE
INVENTORY OF SURPLUS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROPERTY THAT COULD
BE USED. FOR INFILL HOUSING
PROJECTS -- AND THE DECISIONS ON
WHAT TO DO WITH THE SURPLUS
PROPERTY -- AREN'T OUR AND AND
ENTIRELY LEFT LOCAL CONTROL --
AND SO THE GOAL IS TO HELP
CREATE UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SMART PROJECTS TO HELP MEET
OUR HOUSING NEEDS LOCALLY.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES WOULD REPORT --
THE INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WHICH WOULD CREATE -- THIS
DATABASE -- AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORK WITH -- OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAMS WHO IS
CARRYING RELATED LEGISLATION ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC -- AND
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES WHO
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE.
YOUR SUPPORTERS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPEC ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OTHER SUPPORTERS MISTER KEITH
DONE HERE BEHALF CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LAURIE JOHN FROM BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SALINAS AND SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION.
WE'RE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND --
TO THE AUTHOR PRITCHETT YOUR
WORK ON THIS I KNOW THIS IS
BUILDING ON THE GOVERNOR'S --
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER TO HELP
IDENTIFY STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES AND EXPANDING IT TO
LOCAL SURPLUS SITES -- WE ALSO
KNOW THERE'S ANOTHER BILL THAT'S
MOVING TO THE PROCESS -- AND MY
HOPE IS AT SOME POINT WILL
HARMONIZERS PROPOSALS -- AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH
OUR COMMITTEE AND THE OTHER
AUTHOR ON THAT BUT I THINK IN
THE MEANTIME IT MAKES SENSE FOR
THESE PROPOSALS TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT ANY FINAL COMMENTS --
THE ARE AGAIN IS ONE THING STAFF
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING IN THE
SITTING AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET -- YOU KNOW SOME GOOD POLICY
OUT OF IT.
THANK YOU AND RESPECT THAT'S
PRIVATE THANK YOU AND I'LL JUST
NOTE -- THE MEMBERS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
WHICH IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS -- TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CHIU HI TWO I DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA
GLORIA I KILEY LEE MONTH.
THE MONTH I BONTA STONE.
GIVEN UP HOPE TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL WAIT FOR OTHER.
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND WITH THAT
WHEN WE GO TO YOUR SECOND ITEM
WHICH IS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE WANT
SECONDS CHECK
.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN.
SO GET THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
THIS MORNING ABOUT -- AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS
THE FARM WORKER HOUSING ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN I DO
WANT TO THANK FIRST OF ALL THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK PREPARING -- THE ANALYSIS
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY
THAT WE ARE ALL AWARE.
YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL WELL
AWARE THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING A
SEVERE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
AND THE SHORTAGE ISN'T JUST AN
URBAN PROBLEM MANY AGRICULTURE.
AGRICULTURAL AREAS IN OUR STATE
ALSO FACE A HOUSING CRISIS.
IN RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY ONE IN
TEN STUDENTS.
ARE HOMELESS.
AND IN FACT WE HAVE TWELVE
SCHOOLS IN MONTEREY COUNTY WHERE
ONE IN FIVE STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS.
AND IT SURE WOULD ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN SALINAS THAT NUMBER IS
NEARLY FOUR IN.
TEN WE HAVE FAMILIES LIVING
FOURTEEN PEOPLE TO AN APARTMENT.
AND OTHERS ARE SLEEPING IN CARS
OR UNDER FREEWAY OVERPASSES.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY TOUGH ON
OUR FARMWORKERS.
FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY.
AND TOGETHER WITH OUR FAMILY
FARMERS THEY WORK TO BRING THE
FRESHEST PRODUCE TO MARKET.
AND CERTAINLY DO THEIR PART IN
HELPING FEED IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
YET THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE DECENT PLACES FOR
THEM TO LIVE.
AND THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE CREATE A
STREAMLINED PROCESS TO BUILD
FARM WORKER HOUSING ON
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
SETS QUALITY STANDARDS TO ENSURE
THAT THE NEW HOUSING IS
DIGNIFIED AND FAMILY FRIENDLY.
AND PUT SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL ALSO TEARS DOWN LOCAL
RED TAPE.
RED TAPE THAT TOO OFTEN PREVENTS
REZONING OF LAND TO ALLOW FORMER
HOUSING.
LOOK AT THERE IS NO SILVER
BULLET TO SOLVE THIS HOUSING
CRISIS.
BUT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS
A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD
FOR FARMWORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THIS ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
CREATE A TOOL KIT.
A TOOL KIT FOR OUR FARMERS TO
USE IF THEY CHOOSE TO USE IT.
IF THEY WOULD RATHER NOT UTILIZE
IT THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO I'VE SPOKEN TO LOCAL FARMERS
WHO HAVE THANKED ME FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEY WOULD UTILIZE THIS TOOL
THEY WOULD UTILIZE THIS OPTION.
THEY TOLD ME IT WOULD HELP TO
REVITALIZE OUR BUSINESS. TO HELP
THEM BUILD HOUSING FOR THE
WORKERS.
THAT THEY CARE SO MUCH ABOUT.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M NEW TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
I'M NEW TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND AS ONE OF YOUR NEWS
COLLEAGUES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW THAT I
CAN SPEAK FROM EXPERIENCE WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS ISSUE.
YOU SEE MY GRANDFATHER WAS A
FARM WORKER AT ALMADEN VINEYARDS
AND PISCINE THIS CALIFORNIA.
I GREW UP IN FORMER HOUSING.
I LIVE WITH TEN MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY.
OUR HOUSING COMPLEXES LOCATED
RIGHT BESIDE THE VINEYARD WHEN
MY GRANDFATHER WORKED.
OUR HOUSING WAS VERY BASIC.
BUT IT WAS DECENT.
OUR SMALL TWO ROOM HOME GAVE OUR
FAMILY THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR A
BETTER LIFE.
BUT MANY FARMWORKERS THEN AND
NOW.
ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE.
IN THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO WORK
THE FEELS LIKE MY GRANDFATHER
DID.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
CURRENT GENERATION OF
FARMWORKERS THAT THEIR CHILDREN.
ALSO HAVE THE CHANCE AT A BETTER
LIFE AND A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
AND I WANT TO THANK.
KHATAMI LIKE CHAVEZ FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
SHE'S A WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
CAMILA IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE DOORS WHAT THE FOUNDATION
SHE'S ALSO THE NIECE OF SAYS ARE
TRAVIS AND THE DAUGHTER OF THE
GREAT THE DOORS WHAT THE AND
BEING HERE IN THIS ROOM.
WITH HER.
WORKING TOGETHER ON A FARM
WORKER HOUSING BILL IS SURREAL.
IT'S A REAL BECAUSE OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO HER MOTHER DELORES
HUERTA.
TRAVEL TO ALMADEN VINEYARDS IN
SAN BENITO COUNTY. TO HELP MY
GRANDFATHER.
THE MAN WHO RAISED MY BROTHER.
NINE SHE HELPED MY GRANDFATHER
SECURE EQUAL RIGHTS IN THE
FIELDS.
AND BETTER PAY TO SUPPORT HIS
FAMILY OF SEVEN THE LORD'S WORK
THE NEGOTIATED MY GRANDFATHER'S
FIRST UNION CONTRACT.
AND HELPED PAVE THE WAY FOR MY
FAMILY TO GET OUT OF THE FIELDS
AND INTO THE CLASSROOM.
IF IT WERE NOT FOR THE WORK OF
THE LORD WHAT THE I WOULD NOT BE
SITTING HERE TODAY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY.
THIS BILL SEVENTEEN A THREE
CONTINUES THE IMPORTANT WORK
STARTED BY MY GRANDFATHER BY
OTHER HARD WORKING FARMWORKERS.
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY RESIDENT IN
OUR STATE IS TREATED WITH
DIGNITY [inaudible]
AND RESPECT.
AND GIVEN A CHANCE TO ACHIEVE
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
I IMPLORE EACH ONE OF YOU ON
THIS COMMITTEE TO RISE ABOVE
POLITICS. TO CAST A VOTE THAT
WILL BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS.
THERE ARE FORMER BECAUSE ARE
FACING ACROSS THIS STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN
ADDITION -- TO MISS CHAVEZ I'M
ALSO JOINED HERE -- THIS MORNING
BY OUR BILL SPONSOR AND OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
AND I'LL ASK THAT THEY INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE I OFTEN WILL
YOU KNOW -- I'M I MAKE A FARCE
OF ALL THESE NAMES AND AND SO
ALLOW THAN IT IS IT'S OFFICER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BONITA
AVAILABLE STREET MATTER.
I AM THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
REGIONAL OPERATIONS MANAGER IN
THE CENTRAL COAST -- TOO OFTEN
FARMWORKERS ARE AN AFTERTHOUGHT
IN THE STATE CAPITAL.
FEW PEOPLE SEE THE CONDITIONS WE
LIVE IN.
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT ASSEMBLYMAN
REAVIS HAS DECIDED IN ITS FIRST
YEAR OF OFFICE TO PUT
FARMWORKERS FIRST.
THE HISTORY OF OUR MARK A
HOUSING POLICY IN OUR STATE
BEGINS WITH LABOR CAMPS -- LABOR
CAMPS.
DID NOT HAVE THE TENT TENDENCY
PROTECTIONS -- LABOR CAMPS DID
NOT HAVE TITLE TWENTY FOUR
REGULATIONS THEY DID NOT HAVE
STATE.
EXCUSE ME THEY DO NOT HAVE RENT
STABILITY.
THEY WERE COLD DAMP AND INDECENT
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THEY WERE CONTROLLED BY THE
EMPLOYER.
MOST FARMWORKERS DO NOT LIVE IN
LABOR CAMPS TODAY.
BUT IN THE LABOR CAMPS THAT DO
EXIST MANY STILL HAVE BERWICK
STYLE HOUSING.
MOST FARMWORKERS STRUGGLE TO
FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE CROWD INTO SMALL APARTMENTS
LIVE WITH MULTIPLE FAMILIES AND
SMALL HOUSE.
OR RENT OUT GARAGES.
OTHER FARMWORKERS HAVE EVEN
TOUGHER SITUATIONS.
THEY'RE SLEEPING UNDER BRIDGES
SLEEPING IN THE COLD DAMP GROUND.
SLEEPING IN TENTS SLEEPING IN
THEIR CARS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD AND PUTTING ARE IN
DECENT HOUSING POLICIES.
OF THIS STATE WHERE THEY BELONG.
IN THE PAST. FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO CONTINUE BUILDING AND SUPPORT
FARM WORKER HOUSING WITHOUT
TENANTS PROTECTIONS LIKE IN THE
PAST.
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS SAYS YOU
CAN GO BACK WITHOUT THE PUBLIC'S
MONEY. FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
KEEP CONTROL TOTAL CONTROL OVER
EVERY ASPECT OF FARMWORKERS
LIVES THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
SAY YOU CAN GO BACK WITHOUT THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY.
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS SAYS IF
YOU CHOOSE TO GO BACK IN TIME
YOU GO WITH YOU GO BACK WITHOUT
THE PUBLIC'S MONEY OR HELP.
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA RICE ON THE
LITIGATION COORDINATOR FOR
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
THIS YEARLY FOUNDATION HAS BEEN
REPRESENTING AGE TO A WORKERS
AND US WORKERS EMPLOYED UNDER
AGE TO A JOB WORK ORDERS. FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES THIS BILL --
INCLUDES A PROVISION THAT WOULD
LIMIT THE STATE FUNDING BUT NOT
INTERFERE IN ANY WAY WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR H. TO
A WORKERS.
I'M AND I'M HERE TO ADDRESS --
THE PARTICULAR REASONS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THAT SECTION IN THE
BILL AND SUPPORT THE BILL --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THERE'S BEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF EACH WAY
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
INCREASING FROM THREE THOUSAND
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THIS IS STILL A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE TOTAL FARM
WORKER POPULATION THAT IS IN
NEED OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT UNDER THE AGE TO A PROGRAM
GROWERS IN FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS CONTROL NOT ONLY THE
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS.
OF THEIR WORKERS THEY CAN TAKE
THEY CONTROL THE EIGHT ADMISSION
THE DURATION OF THEIR STATE THE
HOUSING THEY LIVE IN THE FOOD
THEY EAT.
HOW THEY GET TO WORK IN THE
MORNING AND WHEN THEY GET HOME
AT NIGHT?
AND THE HOUSING IS PROVIDED THEY
CONTROL NOT JUST A LOCATION BUT
THE BAD THAT THEY SLEEP IN WHO
CAN VISIT THEM WHEN THEY CAN
WHAT THEY CAN DO ON THE PREMISES
AND EVEN WHO CAN VISIT THEM.
AT EVEN WHAT TIME TO GO TO BED
AT NIGHT AND SOME ORDERS.
REPRESENTING THESE WORKERS WE
HAVE SEEN VIOLATIONS AT EVERY
PHASE OF THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP.
WORKERS ARE LIED TO DURING
RECRUITMENT THEY'RE NOT
REIMBURSED FOR THEIR TRAVEL
EXPENSES THEY SUFFER VIOLATIONS
OF CALIFORNIA LABOR AND HOUSING
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW EXISTS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
FROM THIS COUNTRY MUCH LESS A
STATE.
U. S. WORKERS SUFFER THE SAME
VIOLATIONS THE H. TO A WORKERS
WHO WANT TO OBJECT TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE RISKING NOT ONLY THEIR
JOB.
BUT THEIR HOUSING THEIR FOOD AND
THEY'RE VERY RIGHT TO STAY IN
THE UNITED STATES AND WORK.
US WORKERS KNOW THAT IF THEY
DON'T ACCEPT THESE SUB STANDARD
CONDITIONS THERE'S ANOTHER AGE
TO A WORKER WAITING IN THE WINGS
TO TAKE THEIR PLACE IN THE JOB
FORCE.
WITH THE RECENT INCREASE IN AGE
TO A ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS COME A SIGNIFICANT.
SURE ON THE LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IN AREAS LIKE SANTA MARIA LOMPOC
THE SALINAS VALLEY VENTURA
COUNTY AND ELSEWHERE.
PRESSURES BEING PUT ON THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES TESTIFIED
ABOUT WHERE WORKERS WERE
FAMILIES ARE ALREADY DOUBLING UP
AND TRIPLING UP IN ORDER TO
AFFORD HOUSING.
OFTEN AFTER CERTIFICATION EXCUSE
ME DURING CERTIFICATION PROCESS
THESE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE
CERTIFIED TO HOUSE.
TWENTY H. TO A WORKERS.
AFTER CERTIFICATION THAT NUMBER
OFTEN INCREASES TO TWENTY FIVE
OR THIRTY UNLAWFULLY AND THE AND
WORKERS ARE SAID SUBJECTED TO
SUB STANDARD CONDITIONS DURING
THE ENTIRE TERM OF THEIR WORKING
CONTRACT.
THESE HOMES ARE LOCATED IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BENEFIT
DIRECTLY FROM THIS BILL THEY'RE
SORELY LACKING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- AND THEY NEED TO
STREAMLINING PROCESS FOR FOR
APPROVAL THAT'S LAID OUT.
BUT THAT BENEFIT WILL NOT COME
TO THE VAST MAJORITY OF FARMERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES IF THE
EMPHASIS IS ON DEVELOPING
BERWICK STYLE HOUSING FOR H. TO
A WORKERS.
THEREFORE THE EXCEPTION IN THIS
BILL APPLIES.
WE APPRECIATE THE NEED TO HOUSE
H. WAY WORKERS WE UNDERSTAND THE
PER FAST NEED FOR THIS LABOR
STREAM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT INTERFERE IN
ANY WAY WITH THE GROWERS ABILITY
TO HIRE.
THE H. TO A WORKERS OR TO
DEVELOP HOUSING FOR THEM.
BUT IT DOESN'T SURE THAT GOING
FORWARD STATE FUNDS FOR THE
DESPERATELY NEEDED RURAL HOUSING
AND RURAL CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE
DIVERTED TO DEVELOP BERWICK
STYLE HOUSING FOR H. TO A
WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK OF THEIR
THEIR SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
LOUIS MONTANA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS ON
FEDERAL NO PRESIDENT PRIORITY
STRATEGIES BUT HERE ACTUALLY ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS A
BENEFICIARY OF A FORMER HOUSING
THAT DID EMPHASIZE FAMILY
ORIENTED HOUSING AND WHETHER
LOOP IN NORTHERN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY -- I'M A DIRECT
BENEFICIARY AN EXAMPLE OF THE
KIND OF SUCCESS THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE AS A AS A SOCIETY IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY A FORTIES OPPORTUNITIES TO TO
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE YOU KNOW
WORK IN THE FIELDS AND AND DOING
TIRELESS WORK TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE FRESH FOOD ON OUR TABLES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ON A LAWLER WITH
THE WESTERN TERM ON POVERTY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTERING ON TIME BUT WHEN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CAMILLA
CHáVEZ I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE THE LOTUS WORTH
A FOUNDATION AND DAUGHTER OF THE
LOTUS WORTH ANY SUCCESS SUCH
HAVE IS HAVE MANY YEARS GROWING
UP IN THE FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT.
A CURRENTLY THF WORKS AT THE
SCENE ALSO NEED THOSE UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE WORK WITH
THOUSANDS OF FARMWORKERS AND
KERN TO LARRY AND FRESNO
COUNTIES.
FARMWORKERS AS YOU KNOW MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE AND ORGAN AVERAGE
OF EIGHT MONTHS A YEAR.
TODAY AND WE ARE FACING A
SERIOUS HOUSING CRISIS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ALSO NEEDLES
MEMBERS LIVE IN EXTREMELY
CROWDED SPACES.
WE OFTEN ME AND HOUSE MEETINGS
AND OFTEN HAVE TO MEET OUTSIDE
BECAUSE OUR FRANKLY JUST ISN'T
ENOUGH ROOM INSIDE THEIR HOMES
OR TRAILERS WHERE THEY LIVE.
DHL WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AS AN OPTION NOT A MANDATE
FOR FORWARD THINKING AGRICULTURE
COMPANIES AND WE'VE SEEN OTHER A
COMPANY SUCH AS PARAMOUNT FARMS
WHO TRULY INVEST IN THEIR
WORKERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
BY BUILDING HOUSING AND OTHER
RECREATIONAL SERVICES THANK YOU.
LAURIE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SALINAS AND SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
PLEASE IF I COULD ASK -- ONE OR
TWO OF THE WHEN THIS IS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I MATTHEW ON WITH A REPRESENT
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION --
WE REGRETFULLY HAVE TO OPPOSE --
THE BILL TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE'VE HAD TO
DISCUSS FORMER HOUSING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES
AND WITH THE STAFF WE APPRECIATE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
AT AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
REMAINING GAUGED.
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE TRULY
THERE IS A LACK OF AVAILABLE FOR
WILL.
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA -- BEFORE I GET INTO
MORE DETAIL ON THAT I JUST
WANTED A MOMENT JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SINCE IT WAS MENTIONED --
GLORIA FARMS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
TO ABIDE BY ALL FEDERAL LAW IN
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAW AND I AM
NOT DOING SO -- THEY ARE FACED
WITH -- PENALTIES -- IN AND THE
THE VIOLATIONS THAT WOULD GO
WITH ALSO A TWENTY MAKE THAT
CLEAR -- IS PART OF DISCUSSION.
IN RELATION -- TO SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WE'RE HAVE DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MINISTER OF
PERMITTING PROCESS BECAUSE IT'S
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE UNLESS
THE FARMER TURNS OPERATION OF
THEIR HOUSING OVER TO A THIRD
PARTY QUALIFIED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS.
FEW FARMERS WOULD BE WILLING TO
DO THIS AS THEY WOULD REMAIN
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HOUSING.
AND ANY LIABILITY CLAIMS
ASSOCIATED WITH -- ITS OPERATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
INSTEAD COMMIT TO FINDING AN
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION THAT DOES
NOT DISCOURAGE FARMERS FROM
DEPLOYING THEIR CAPITAL AND
THEIR LAND TO MEET THIS URGENT
NEED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALSO HAVE A
CONCERN REGARDING LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL REGARDING THE
PROHIBITION ON UTILIZING STATE
FUNDS -- FOR HOUSING REGARDING --
EACH TO EMPLOYEES THE REALITY IS
THAT FARMERS HERE AND ELSEWHERE
IN THE U. S. ARE TURNING TO THE
H. TO A PROGRAM IN DESPERATION
DUE TO THE ONGOING LABOR
SHORTAGE.
IN AGRICULTURE.
THE THIRD POINT WE WANTED TO
BRING UP IS THAT THE BILL
APPEARS TO TIE -- TENET HOUSING
RIGHTS.
TO CURRENT EMPLOYEE HOUSING
RIGHTS WHEN THE TO REALLY SHOULD
REMAIN DISTINCT BECAUSE THE
HOUSING CIRCUMSTANCES FOR BOTH
ARE ENTIRELY DIFFERENT AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL [inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
NOTATE JACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NURSING GARDEN CENTERS
CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER COMMISSION.
AND AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS
AGAIN REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH US --
BUT WE ARE OPPOSED FOR THE SAME
REASONS AS WAS MENTIONED BY
WESTERN GROWERS REPRESENTATIVE --
AND JUST WANT TO LOOK TOWARDS
BETTER SOLUTIONS -- FOR EXAMPLE --
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES THAT WE
FACE IN OTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE HAD SOME MEMBERS THAT WERE
BUILDING HOUSING ON THE CENTRAL
COAST.
MADE IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
SEQUEL PROCESS AND IT WAS FOR
FAMILY HOUSING.
AND THEN IN THOSE HOUSES BEFORE
THEY CAN BE COMPLETED REX LEE
BURN DOWN BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY SO WE'RE DEALING WITH
A LOT OF ISSUES LIKE THAT WE
LOVE TO TALK TO THE AUTHOR --
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES HOW WE CAN
WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT MORE OF THESE
HOUSES CAN BE BUILT AND ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DISCOURAGING.
FARMERS FROM COMMITTING THEIR
LAND IN CAPITAL TO THIS TYPE OF
HOUSING THANK YOU.
MORNING DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF FAMILY WINE MAKERS IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING A THREE MILLION --
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA PEAR GROWERS
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION --
I THINK I'LL JUST ASK A QUICK
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR IN YOUR
SUPPORTERS IF YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION -- I DON'T THINK SO I
YOU KNOW I THINK -- ULTIMATELY.
MYSELF AND STAFF -- YOU KNOW.
BE HAPPY TO ME WITH WITH WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND ULTIMATELY
WE CREATED A BILL THAT -- IS
SIMPLY AN OPTION YOU KNOW NOBODY
HAS TO UTILIZE -- THIS BILL --
BUT CERTAINLY IT DOES ADDRESS
THE NEED FOR THE DISTRICT AND I
THINK -- MANY OF US WILL AGREE
THAT THIS IS A BILL YOU KNOW
THAT MOST POLICY THAT COMES OUT
OF THIS BUILDING SHOULD BE
DRIVEN BY GOOD DATA.
AND SO DATA WAS THIS IT WAS IT
WAS THE PRIMARY REASON WHY YOU
KNOW WE CREATE THIS BILL AND
WHEN AND WHY SAY ABOUT DATA IN
JULY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE
WAS A FARM WORKER HOUSING STUDY
AN ACTION PLAN.
THAT WAS RELEASED -- IT WAS --
IT WAS CONDUCTED.
SO IT WAS RELEASED IN JULY BUT
WAS CONDUCTED BY THE SALINAS
APOLLO VALLEY'S -- AND WHAT THE
STUDY SAID IS IT IT COME FROM
THE AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ARE
LIVING AND SEVERELY OVERCROWDED --
THESE CONDITIONS SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS -- AND THE STUDY
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE WAS A
PREPONDERANCE OF WORKERS THAT
WERE YEAR ROUND RESIDENTS.
AND THOSE THAT WERE SURVEYED 75%
OF THE PEOPLE I WAS A WE WERE
MARRIED AND OFTEN LIVE IN A
HOUSEHOLD WITH MINOR CHILDREN
AND SO THE BASICALLY THIS DATA
WHAT.
THE YOU KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL
PLAN SUGGESTED WAS THAT MUCH OF
THE FOCUS THAT HAS BEEN PUT ON
ON ON HOUSING FOR TEMPORARY
FARMWORKERS.
THAT THE DATA THAT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY CLEAR THAT THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT NEED WAS FOR
PERMANENT FARM WORKER FAMILY
HOUSING AND SO CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW IN A PERFECT WORLD
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WOULD
GET THEIR ACT TOGETHER CONGRESS
AND FIX IMMIGRATION -- THE WE
SHOULDN'T BE DEPENDING ON A
GUEST WORKER PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW
FOR ALL THESE YEARS THAT WE HAVE --
CERTAINLY THIS IS A POLITICAL
ISSUE AND CONGRESS THESE DO
SOMETHING AND AND GET REAL ABOUT
IMMIGRATION REFORM -- BUT THIS
IS CERTAINLY A STATE SOLUTION.
TO A STATEWIDE PROBLEM -- AND
THAT'S WHAT WE OUR ATTENDED TO
CONSERVE THIS BILL.
AND AGAIN JUST A TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS -- AGAIN
THIS BILL IS OPTIONAL IT DOES
NOT LIMIT ANY GROWER OR OTHER
AGRICULTURE ENTERPRISE FROM
DEVELOPING HOUSING FARMER
HOUSING WHAT IT DOES IS.
EXEMPT THEM FROM THE PROCESS
UNLESS THEY AGREED TO WORK WITH
A THIRD PARTY.
CURRENTLY MANY GROWERS AND
OPERATORS WORK WITH THIRD
PARTIES TO PROVIDE THEIR HOUSING
ANYWAY YEAH IT'S NOT A HUGE
CHANGE FROM THE BUSINESS
PRACTICE THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS --
THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF AB
EXAMPLES WHERE THAT'S THE CASE
MONTEREY COUNTY -- THAT THIS
BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THAT
AND ALL OF THOSE OPTIONS ARE
STILL AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU -- IS LIMóN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AT TO THE
AUTHOR I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
OPPOSITION AND I DON'T KNOW IF
WE CAN GET OPPOSITION.
SO ONE OF THE THE ELEMENTS IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED MULTIPLE TIMES IS
THAT THIS BILL IS OPTIONAL.
AND DOES NOT IT DOES NOT HAVE TO
BE ADOPTED BY ANY -- FARMER THAT
DOES NOT CAN YOU RESPOND TO THAT
AND WHY YOU WOULD STILL OPPOSE
SOMETHING THAT'S OPTIONAL NOT
REQUIRED.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION -- I
PROBABLY A COUPLE POINTS ON THAT --
THERE'S DEFINITELY A LABOR
SHORTAGE ISSUE OUT THERE AND
WERE HAVING ISSUES REALLY THE
NIMBY.
NIMBY AS AND WHEN THAT'S
OCCURRING UNFORTUNATELY
REGARDING FARMER HOUSING -- AND
WE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW THE THE
THE THE ISSUE COMES.
TO IT'S A CRISIS -- IT'S IT'S
WERE PICKING UP PRODUCTION AG
LAND ACTUALLY SITE THE HOUSING
USING OUR OWN CAPITAL WE'RE
GOING TO STILL BE ALIVE ON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A MINISTER OR
MINISTER PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
THIS TYPE OF HOUSING YEARS AGO
BECAUSE REALLY NOT ARGUING ABOUT
IS OWNING TYPE ISSUE.
WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED THAT A
BILL THAT THIS BILL PICKETT
SIGNED -- GETS UP DOWNSTAIRS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND GET SIGNED.
THAT IS REALLY NOT GONNA LEAD TO
MORE HOUSING GOING IN BECAUSE WE
HAVE.
A LOT OF A GROWERS ARE JUST NOT
GOING TO TURN THE KEYS OVER IN
ORDER TO FOLLOW THE MINISTER
PERMITTING PROCESS.
AND WE COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND
SAY WE HAVE AN ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM -- THAT WE'RE STILL
HAVING A A FORMER HOUSING
SHORTAGE OF THAT WERE
UNFORTUNATE TO BE TOLD THAT WE
TRY TO DRESS AT LAST YEAR AND
WE'RE WORRIED.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT IS REALLY A
CRISIS AND WE LIKE OUR HANDS ARE
BEING TIED UNNECESSARILY.
THANKS FOR THE FEEDBACK I GUESS
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS ONLY MY MY THIRTY YEAR
ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND I
FEEL LIKE WE CONTINUE TO BRING
TOOLS KNOWING THAT NOT ONE TOOL
IS THE FINAL SOLUTION.
SO I GUESS THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION ON MY PART THAT WE
WILL COME BACK NEXT YEAR
INDEPENDENT OF THIS BILL GET
SIGNED OR NOT BECAUSE WE NEED
MORE THAN ONE TOOL FOR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES -- AND CERTAINLY
THIS ISSUE AT I THINK BOTH THE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION MENTON
THE CENTRAL COAST WHICH IS --
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
AND BOTH ENTER AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY HAVE AG AG IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BOTH OF THOSE
COUNTIES -- BUT WE CAN'T HAVE AG
ACCURATE AG PRODUCTION WITHOUT
FARMWORKERS -- AND THE HOUSING
ISSUE CONTINUES TO BE -- ONE I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR AND I HAVE
HAD MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS I AND
THE OTHER THAT YOU KNOW ELEMENT
THAT I'VE EXPRESSED AND IN TERMS
OF MY CONCERN AND THIS HAS GONE
FOR A NUMBER OF OF BILLS THAT
WE'VE SEEN NOT JUST AROUND
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT BUT OTHER
DEVELOPMENT.
IS WHEN WE FAST FORWARD -- OR
STREAMLINER AT WHATEVER RATE.
AT WORD OF THE DAY WE DECIDE --
SOME ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT --
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE
INTERFACE BETWEEN URBAN AND AG
CREATES COMPLICATIONS.
AND THERE ARE A I THINK HAVING
LIVED AND CONTINUING TO LIVE
SOME OF THE COMPLICATIONS --
THAT IT CREATES -- I THINK WE DO
HAVE TO BE VERY SENSITIVE TO
WHAT IT MEANS AT TO BUILD IN AN
AREA -- WHERE URBAN AND NAGY
INTERFACE -- WHERE IS THAT
COMMUNITY CHANGES -- THE
CONCERNS MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
TODAY THAN THEY WILL BE IN TEN
YEARS -- CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN
THAT -- AND HAPPEN AND SO I I
WANT.
I WORRY SOMETIMES THAT WE FAST
FORWARD OR STREAMLINE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS -- IN
ORDER TO GET SOMETHING DONE
BECAUSE THE NEED IS SO HIGH AND
I THINK THERE'S MERIT IN HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION BUT
PARTICULARLY AROUND FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE AG AND
URBAN INTERFACE IN A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY THAN IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES -- I I WORRY I ALSO
WORRY -- I KNOW THAT DEPENDING
ON THE SIDE THAT PEOPLE ARE ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
AND REVIEW PROCESS CAN BE USED
AS A SORT FOR BOTH SIDES.
AND I ALSO FIND THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ARE ON THE NOT SO GREAT
RECEIVING SIDE OF THIS -- IT
MEANING THAT SOMETIMES WE OVER
RIGHT PROTECTIONS -- Là AND WE
FIND OURSELVES THE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ARE IN AREAS WITH THE
WORST AIR QUALITY WITH -- WATER
ISSUES WITH LAND CONTAMINATION
ISSUES BECAUSE THERE WAS SOME
ELEMENTS THAT WERE FAST
FORWARDED -- AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT SOMETIMES ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENT TO PROTECTIONS.
THAT CAN BE USED -- BY FOLKS.
WHO HAVE DIFFERENT CONCERNS IN
MINE AND AND SLOWED YOU KNOW IN
COULD POTENTIALLY SLOW DOWN THE
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE TO FIND A
WAY? TO BUILD HOUSING AND ALSO
PROTECT THE COMMUNITY -- AGAIN I
WOULD BE HAPPY HAVE
CONVERSATIONS IT SOUNDS LIKE
BOTH OPPOSITION -- AND
SUPPORTERS TALKED ABOUT THE
CENTRAL COAST IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES -- MAY AND IT'S HARD
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS BECAUSE
THE ONE A ONE MIGHT NOT BE THERE
IN FIFTY YEARS IF WE DO SEE SEA
LEVEL RISE ENTRANCE -- TATIAN
WILL BE AN ISSUE -- BECAUSE WE
ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO NATURAL
DISASTERS -- SINCE WE HAVE A FEW
NO NATIONAL FOREST SURROUNDING
US -- IT IN SO I WANT THOSE TO
BE CONSIDERED -- I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR IS SOMEONE WHO CARES A
LOT ABOUT THE SAME THINGS AND
AND THAT HAS BEEN EVIDENT IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS ARE THAT WE'VE HAD
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL -- AND CERTAINLY --
I A THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO IDENTIFY -- AND ESTABLISH
THAT THIS COULD BE ONE TOOL --
EIGHT YOU KNOW IT SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS -- BUT THIS WON'T BE THE
BE ALL AND SOLVE ALL -- I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
WILL BE EVALUATING AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD WHERE I'M AT I
THINK CONVERSATION NEEDS TO
CONTINUE -- BUT I DO HOPE THAT
WE INCLUDE SOME OF THE MORE YOU
KNOW THE EASIER QUESTIONS ARE
THE THE THE FIRST THAT WE ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE ANSWERED BUT
THERE SOME HARDER WHEN -- AS
WELL [inaudible]
MR STONE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU A
SERVICE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
YOU AND I ALSO HAD CONVERSATIONS
AROUND THIS AND I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT AND LOG YOUR GOALS TO
GET MORE FORMER HOUSING WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
AND AS BOTH OF US BE REPRESENT
AS OF THE NORTHERN END OF THE
CENTRAL COAST.
JUST LOOKING FOR THE KNOWLEDGE
BUT THAT'S THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY CRITICAL BUT I WILL
ALSO.
SO MY CONCERNS THOUGH ARE THIS
NOTION OF STREAMLINING WE WE
HAVE ARE STARTING TO CREATE THIS
NOTION THAT SEQUEL IS THE THE
ANSWER GETTING RID OF SEEK OR
DOING SOME BASIC WAS THE ANSWER
TO OUR PROBLEMS.
STATISTICALLY THAT'S JUST NOT
THE CASE IT'S BECOME AN
UNNECESSARY WHIPPING.
BOY TO THE PROCESS HERE AND IF
THAT'S OUR FOCUS I THINK WE
FORGET THE OTHER THINGS WE NEED
TO BE DOING.
BY CREATING PROJECTS LIKE THIS
AS MINISTERIAL PERMITS WE WHAT
IS REALLY BEING DONE IS WE'RE
TAKING THE PUBLIC PROCESS IS
SICK OR PRESENTS.
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION.
AND THERE.
WAS A RECENT VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT THAT YOU KNOW WOULD IN
SPRECKELS THAT.
WENT THROUGH THAT FULL PROCESS
NOW THAT IS ONE THAT IS BEING
RUN BY THE GROWER THAT'S NOT A
PART OF YOUR BILL THAT I HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH YOUR I WILL I
WILL DEFINITELY SUPPORTER THAT.
BUT IT WENT THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS AND THE GROWER THERE THE
DEVELOPER WAS VERY SMART AND HOW.
THEY ENGAGED THE THE FOLKS WHO
TYPICALLY PUSHED BACK AND WANT
TO PROTECT SEQUIN ARE VERY
WORRIED ABOUT DEVELOPMENT.
THAT ACTUALLY GOT ENTITLED
FAIRLY QUICKLY AND WITHOUT A LOT
OF GRIEF AND PAIN BECAUSE THEY
DID THE WORK UP FRONT WHICH IS
WHAT I HAVE FOUND IN MY
EXPERIENCE AS A LOCAL ELECTED.
IS WHAT LEADS TO SEE WHAT
PROBLEMS IS AN UNWILLINGNESS TO
DO THE WORK UP FRONT TO TALK TO
STAKEHOLDERS AND TO TO BUILD.
THAT THE CASE FOR DEVELOPMENT SO
THE PART THAT WORRIES ME IS THIS
CREATION OF A MINISTERIAL
PROCESS FOR THAT WHICH THIS YEAR
IF THIS GOES THROUGH.
OF TAKING THE PUBLIC OF OUT OF A
LOT OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND I
THINK.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD THING THAT
ALMOST SOME PLACES GUARANTEES
FURTHER STRIFE DOWN THE LINE AND
MORE LAWSUITS AROUND IT BECAUSE
THE DEVELOPERS ARE NOT AS
INCLINED. TO ENGAGE WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE IN BE OPPONENTS TO
A PROJECT OR OR WHO WOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
SO I I WOULD JUST ASK I'M I'M A
GUEST HERE TODAY AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT I'M GONNA DEFINITELY FOLLOW
THE CHAIR ON INDIAN.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD HAD ASKED
TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
ABOUT THAT MOVING FORWARD AND
NOT CREATING A PROCESS THAT
EXCLUDES LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
INVOLVEMENT IN A LOT OF THE
DECISIONS THAT GET MADE.
ABOUT WHERE HOUSING GOES WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE AND IT'S THAT SEQUEL
PROCESS THAT ENFORCES.
THE WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THEM BECAUSE THOSE
PRIDE THAT PROJECT AND THERE'S
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S PROPOSING
CASTRO ABOUT.
SOME OF THE COMMUNITY CONCERNS
THERE ARE WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE IF
THEY'RE GONNA BE SOARED WILL
BERWICK STYLE IF YOU THEY'RE
JUST HOUSING PEOPLE HOUSE PEOPLE
THOSE ISSUES OF ALL COME UP.
AND THE DEVELOPER REALLY HAD TO
ADDRESS THOSE.
BANKRATE ENVIRONMENT RECOGNIZING
THAT IT'S THE THE NATURE OF
FARMWORKERS WHO THEY ARE WHAT
THEY ARE THAT THEY ARE FAMILIES
THAT THEY HAVE BROADER NEEDS.
THAN HAD BEEN SEEN IN THE PAST
BECAME A VERY GOOD PART OF THE
CONVERSATION SO I JUST DON'T
WANT TO LOSE THOSE ASPECTS OF IT
IN A RUSH TO GET HOUSING DONE.
WHICH WE SHOULD BE DOING AND I
KNOW YOU AGREE WITH THAT AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT THERE ARE SOME PROCESSES WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL OF THAT WE'RE
NOT OVERSTEPPING AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT HASN'T ALWAYS PROVEN TO
BE.
A STUMBLING BLOCK I THINK WE
PRESUME A STUMBLING BLOCK WHERE
THERE ISN'T NECESSARILY ONE AND
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO GET OVER
SOME OF THE CHALLENGE TO GET
BROUGHT UP BUT THANK YOU.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND AND CLEARLY I AND
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THE YOU KNOW.
MYSELF MY STAFF THAT WOULD
CONTINUE THE WORK WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL -- THE COMMUNITY
WITH AND AND AND CERTAINLY WITH
WITH -- YOU KNOW ALL OF YOU AND
AND MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE CONTINUE STRAIGHT AND
THIS BILL FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW I THAT'S
SOMETHING I'M REALLY OPEN TO A
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS -- AND YOU KNOW I I I I
SHOULD MENTION THAT.
IN THE SALINAS VALLEY I COMMAND --
WE'RE VERY CLOSELY WITH WITH
WITH AGRICULTURE THERE ON THIS
BILL.
AND YOU ASIDE FROM THE COMMENTS
FROM -- YOU KNOW MY FRIEND FROM
WATCHING GROWERS.
YOU KNOW THEY REALLY AG THOSE AG.
I COMPANIES AG OPERATES HAVE
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND TO CREATE
DECENT HOUSING FOR ALL WORKERS --
IN IN IN THIS REGION -- AND THAT
SHOULD BE NOTED I WOULD ALSO
SHOULD BE NOTED ON THE LARGER
FARMS THE OPERATION THAT MR
STONE ELUDED -- TO WHAT WHAT
WITH WHICH WAS BY TEN MARIN
ANTEL -- WHICH WAS INTENDED TO
BE AN H. TO A PROJECT.
BUT LO AND BEHOLD PART OF OUR
BILL YOU KNOW A BIG PART OF OUR
BILLS AGAIN THIS IS A TOOL AND
PART OF THAT TOOL IS RECRUITING
AND HOPEFULLY STABILIZING AG
LABOR IN THE STATE.
LOW AND BEHOLD WHEN YOU BUILD IT
THEY WILL COME.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS AGE TO
A INTENDED HOUSING PROJECT IS NO
LONGER IN AGE TO A PROJECT IS A
PERMANENT PROJECT FOUR EIGHT
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED IS WHEN
THEY BUILT IT STABILIZED THEIR
LABOR NEEDS -- AT TI NA AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE TO
INTEND YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S A
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S AN OPTION
BUT IT IS A TOOL AND WE THINK
THAT IT'LL GO A LONG WAY. TO
ADDRESS NEEDS FROM LOCAL FARMERS.
IS THERE ARE OTHER DISCUSSION
LIKE MANY.
MOTION MOVED THERE'S A SECOND --
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS -- THIS
COMMITTEE SPENDS AN AWFUL LOT OF
TIME THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
EXPAND.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND URBAN
AREAS AND SUBURBAN AREAS BUT WE
DO NOT SPENT ENOUGH TIME
THINKING OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IN A RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND SPECIFICALLY AROUND FARM
WORKER HOUSING -- BEFORE I GOT
TO KNOW THE AUTHOR SINCE HE IS
NEW HERE -- I WAS ASKED TO CARRY
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WERE
IN THIS BILL.
AND WHEN I DISCOVERED -- NOT
ONLY AUTHORS BACKGROUND AND HIS
PERSONAL COMMITMENT AS PASSION --
I WAS I AM VERY VERY HAPPY --
THAT THIS BILL IS MOVING FORWARD
AND REALLY TRAINING CORPORATION
A NUMBER OF OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IN THIS AREA FROM
CREATING MORE INCENTIVES TO
BUILD THE KIND OF HOUSING THAT
WE NEED. TO CLOSING LOOPHOLES
THAT ALLOWED THAT HAD ALLOWED
THE STATE TO SPEND OUR LIMITED
HOUSING RESOURCES ON HOUSING --
THE FARMERS WOULD HAVE BEEN
OTHERWISE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE AS
WELL AS ENSURING SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR FARMWORKERS WHO
ARE TENANTS -- AND SO BECAUSE OF
THAT I AM RECOMMENDING AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS FOR I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
BILL TO REALLY BE THE VEHICLE
FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
I CERTAINLY HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THERE ARE
CONTINUED ISSUES IN MY HOPE IS --
THAT EVERYONE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER THAT WE REALLY USE
THIS BILL TO SURFACE THE BEST
IDEAS AND HOW WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
IT ALSO SO I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR IS VERY COMMITTED -- TO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE NOT WE CAN
IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS --
AND WILL WORK ON THAT -- SO WITH
THAT -- IF THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE
I'M ALSO HAPPY BE ADDED AS AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL -- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE TAKEN THE
AMENDMENTS -- THAT WERE ASKED
FOR IN THIS COMMITTEE SO MRS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION.
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS -- I DO IN AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
ALL MY COLLEAGUES HERE I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT I REMAIN
ABSOLUTELY -- COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL SIDES IN AND
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THIS
ISSUE -- AND WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW
MY STAFF MYSELF WE'VE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY TRANSPARENT IN THIS
PROCESS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE IN RESPECT ON THIS
MATTER.
OF I WANT TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT
HERE AND CERTAINLY THIS BILL AB
SEVENTY THREE SIMPLY CREATE A
TOOL AN OPTION. FOR FARMERS TO
UTILIZE IF THEY'RE WILLING AND
ABLE -- AND I I IMPLORE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL ARE
FARMWORKERS CERTAINLY NEED OUR
HELP.
AND LET'S KEEP THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ALIVE FOR THEM AND FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND AGAINST CHAIR --
AND FELLOW MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
AND RESPECTFULLY -- ASPIRIN I'VE.
WITH THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED MEDIA
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU HI.
HI DAVE.
I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA
GLORIA I KILEY.
AND FOR THE MONTH.
I BONTA.
HI.
I STONE.
STONE.
YOUR BILL WILL MOVE UP.
WHEN WE MOVED TO OUR FINAL ITEM
AND THAT'S FROM MS IRWIN FILE
ITEM THREE AB SIX PENSION BOND
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN TO
AUTHORIZE THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING?
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROP TWELVE THE
VETERANS BOND ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AUTHORIZING NINE
HUNDRED MILLION IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS INTENDED TO
HELP VETERANS PURCHASE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
FARMS AND MOBILE HOMES IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AB SIX THREE AT NINE
RESTRUCTURED THE VETERANS OF
BOND ACTIVE TWENTY OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AUTHORIZING SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN EXISTING BOND
AUTHORITY. TO FIND MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING FOR VETERANS CREATING V.
H. H. P..
OVER FOUR ROUNDS OF FUNDING VH
HP HAS PROVIDED. TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY TWO TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS TO VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THERE IS NOW
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
LEFT FOR V. H. H. P. AT THE RATE
OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION PER
ROUND.
THAT FUNDING WILL RUN OUT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO GET A BOND
ON THE TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT THE
BILL WOULD HAVE TO PASS THIS
YEAR OR WITH AN URGENCY NEXT
YEAR.
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED TWELVE
THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN MORE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
ACCORDING TO AGE CD
APPROXIMATELY 79% OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS WHO RENTERS SPENDING
MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR INCOME ON
HOUSING.
AB SIX NINE FOUR WILL ASSIST
VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS OR
NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSE RENTAL
HOUSING TO SECURE HOUSING FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT ABOUT
[inaudible] TWO WITNESSES.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
THIS MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH DONE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR ALEX TOURISM HALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION MOVES ARE
SECOND [inaudible]
ANY DISCUSSION.
THIS ONE OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
VETERANS HOUSING -- THISIS NOT
THE FIRST TIME YOU MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THAT LED TO THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION ONE LAST
YEAR WHICH DID INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR VETERANS
HOUSING.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS IS
CERTAINLY A CATEGORY OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION THAT WE WANT
TO END IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO IT BUT WE
OBVIOUSLY NEED THE FUNNY TO DO
SO -- THERE IS ONE ASPECT OF
THIS BILL THAT -- OUR COMMITTEE
HAD THOUGHT ABOUT AND THAT WAS
WHETHER WE NEEDED TO REQUIRE AN
ACTUAL AMOUNT THAT BE PART OF
THIS AND I'LL JUST ASK OR
MENTION A COLLEAGUES.
WE DECIDED TO NOT ASK THE AUTHOR
AT THIS TIME FOR THAT BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT'S A
CONVERSATION SHE WE HAVING -- IN
FURTHER LEGISLATIVE STEPS AND
CERTAINLY WITH LEADERSHIP SO --
WE KNOW THAT WILL BE WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT SPECIFIC NUMBER
AS WE MOVE FORWARD BUT I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL MOVING OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS ANY
THAT WE KNOW EXISTS.
AND WITHOUT MUSSER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
OF JUST -- ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
RIGHT THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
VETERAN OF HERS I TO HI CHIU I
GAVE.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY.
LIMóN.
THE MONTH I BONTA BONTA AYE
STONE STONE HI.
YOUR BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT WRAPS UP TODAY'S AGENDA
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH FILE ORDER
IT TO ADD ON MISSING MEMBERS AND
I THINK THERE A COUPLE OF ITEMS
WE ACTUALLY STILL NEED TO TAKE A
MOTION -- WHY DON'T WE JUST GO
THROUGH FILE OVER AND AS WE NEED
A MOTION I WILL ASK FOR ONE FILE
ITEM?
ONE MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I BONTA.
BONTA AYE STONE.
STONE HI. SIXTY ZERO SIX ZERO
THAT ITEM IS OUT FILE ITEM.
TO AB SIXTY NINE TANK.
KILEY.
KILEY I BONTA.
BONTA I STONE STONE I AS A TWO
ZERO THAT ITEM IS ALSO OUT WE
JUST TOOK FILE ITEM THREE AND I
THINK EVERYONE HERE HAS HAD A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON THAT -- FILE
ITEM FOR I BELIEVE WE NEED A
MOTION AND SECOND.
IS OUR SECOND.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU
HI CHIU I TAPE.
THE I GABRIELLE.
HI GABRIEL HI GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY AYE IN THE MONTH.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE STONE STONE HI. SEVEN
ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT FILE ITEM
FIVE LET'S AT ON THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
KILEY.
KILEY I A BONTA.
BONTA AYE STONE STONE I ME
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
THAT ITEM IS OUT -- LET'S MOVE
TO FILE ITEM SIX AT ON THE ANY
MISSING MEMBERS -- WE DO I'M.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE STONE STONE HI. EIGHT
TWO EIGHT ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT
LET'S GO TO FILE ITEM SEVEN I
THINK WE NEED A MOTION.
IS OUR MOTION TO PHYLUM SEVEN
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
TWO FIVE TWO HI DAVE HI I
GABRIEL.
APRIL I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MON.
THE MINE I BONTA.
BONTA AYE STONE STONE HI. EIGHT
TWO ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT ITEM IS
OUT AND FIVE EIGHT I THINK WE
HAD.
EVERYONE WHO VOTED WHO WANTS TO
VOTE -- WITH THAT THANK YOU.
FOR EVERYONE TO TENANTS AND AT
THIS TIME THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
YEAH